[Musique]
bonjour brison à glace et faisons
connaissance vous est il déjà arrivé
d'être embarrassée par une question
anodine vous savez celle composent l'air
de rien justement pour faire
connaissance
êtes vous mariée
avez vous des enfants
quel âge avez vous vous faites quoi dans
la vie
moi il y en avait une lorsque j'étais
enfant qui n'était particulièrement
difficile une de ces questions anodines
à laquelle tout le monde répondait
facilement n'est pas moi combien as-tu
deux frères et soeurs
simple non oui mais pas pour moi j'ai
longtemps répondu cinq je l'écrivais
aussi sur mes fiches de rentrée scolaire
mais le problème c'est que d'une année
sur l'autre d'un professeur à l'autre
c'était pas souvent les mêmes réponses
allaient même nom et parfois même pas le
même nombre
alors vous demander pourquoi j'avais
besoin de venir mentir sur une question
aussi banal pourquoi
c'est simple j'avais honte
honte de dire qu'en réalité j'ai
vingt-trois presse et oui vous avez bien
entendu
23 et si je me risque à le révéler un
tas de ces questions sont suivis sont
ils tous de la même mère
combien de frères combien de feurs alors
j'ai pas compté mais je me penche est-ce
que vous avez tous vécu ensemble non
plus mais une dernière votre père est-il
polygame alors pas officiellement
bref une foultitude de questions et je
devenais cette bête de foire cette
hauteur the box elle qu'il ne rentrait
pas dans les cases
j'étais si honteuse
mois cet art of the box
si ni te c'est emilie et j'avais qu'une
envie c'est disparaître au fond de mon
lit
ayant grandi en france je reconnais que
c'est renens jusqu'au jour où j'ai
réalisé que c'était une force
ce qui pour les autres étaient une
question banale traité en à peine deux
secondes était pour moi une aubaine de
faire de cette question simplement posé
sur la forme une réelle argumentation
sur ma culture
mais différence ma singularité
et cerise sur le gâteau ça m'a même
éviter des sujets complexes en entretien
de concours bref c'est comme ça je suis
né quelque part
on choisit pas ses parents on choisit
pas sa famille
on choisit pas non plus les trottoirs de
manille de paris ou d'alger pour
apprendre à marcher
être né quelque part
être né quelque part pour celui qui est
né c'est toujours un hasard
un hassar et pour autant est-ce que cela
va m'empêcher d'arriver là où je veux
aller
durant ces quelques minutes je vais vous
distribuer les cartes de ce que je crois
être les bonnes pour déjouer les
pronostics de sa destinée pour devenir
ce que nous voulons être indépendamment
de là où nous sommes et
à n'en pas douter j'ai eu de la chance
dans mon parcours la chance des succès
inattendus des rendez-vous hasardeuse
mais cette chance
n'était ce qu'une question de chance ah
ça non j'ai travaillé d'arrache-pied il
n'y a je crois pas de secret à la
réussite si ce n'est le travail l'audace
et la ténacité
vous êtes issu d'une minorité
quelle qu'elle soit vous venez d'un
milieu défavorisé vous êtes une femme
comme moi vous êtes vus comme un fils à
papa une fille à papa
vous sentez out of the box où vous êtes
vous
simplement vous et bien la recette est
la même
alors il vous faudra parfois de son
doublé les doses et je sais de quoi je
parle rien ne me prédisposait à la vie
que je mène aujourd'hui
enchanté
je m'appelle tania gombert
j'ai 42 ans je suis cadre dans le
secteur des assurances et j'ai dès l'âge
de 30 ans intégrer les instances de
direction alors je suis la maman des
deux plus belles petites filles du monde
et puis intelligente et puis sublimer
piché objective je vis avec un homme
merveilleux au sein d'un couple dans
lequel je cultive allaigrement mon
incompétence ménagères
origine la chanson
mais ça n'a pas toujours été ainsi et
malgré mon réveil brutal sur l'inégalité
des chances je ne crois pas au
déterminisme
je crois en la détermination
non tout n'est pas joué tout n'est pas
déterminée dès sa naissance
de par sa filiation de par ses gènes ou
de par ses croyances
croire en cela c'est croire au fatalisme
dû déterminer
[Musique]
selon vous quelle était la destinée
d'une petite fille née à madagascar
dunaire jeunes seuls et sans un sou
alors
naître à madagascar c'est naître dans
l'un des pays les plus pauvres au monde
[Musique]
tristement connue pour son tourisme
sexuel et pour la prostitution des
jeunes femmes
alors je vous leur demande quelle était
ma destinée
je veux dire aux jeunes aux moins jeunes
finalement à vous tous vous un jour qui
a bien entendu tu n'y arriveras pas ou
un autre ça n'est pas ta place
personne ne va te la donner ta place
cette place tu la veux tu es visualise
son épanouissement
alors prends la enfonce les portes
contredit les mauvaises langues aux
hausser la voix osent dire qui tu es ta
culture des différents stages
singularité et c'est cette attitude
combative qui je viens jouer un mauvais
tour au fatalisme du déterminisme c'est
la détermination
alors vous me direz à tania c'est bien
beau la détermination s'est moqué du
déterminisme et so what
mettons les cartes sur table voilà ce
que j'ai appliqué et que j'aurais aimé
qu'on me dise
tout d'abord apprend à t'aimer joue de
la carte amour de soi oui j'ai pu j'ai
oui j'ai dû tout d'abord apprendre à
aimer apprendre à mai mais pour outre
passé toutes ces questions de valeurs
alors c'est peut-être plus facile pour
certains que pour d'autres mais il faut
se le répéter chaque jour je m'aime j'ai
de la valeur et ce jusqu'à en être
convaincu
je me souviens m'être dit souvent il pas
dans un excès de narcissisme en jeu même
pour toutes les personnes qui lie à sur
cette terre
j'avais 11 ans je venais de subir des
moqueries du racisme
mais il était hors de question que je ne
cède aux sirènes du laisser-aller
du jeu laisse tomber je ne vaux rien ils
ont raison
non ça demain tu as pas moi ça ne
m'atteint pas ça ne nous attendent pas
parce que nous nous nous répétons chaque
jour je m'aime j'ai de la valeur je
m'aime pour toutes les personnes qu'il
ya sur cette terre apprêtée
être différence ne signifie pas avoir
plus ou moins de valeur
réfléchissons ensemble
calais l'antonyme de différents s égal
non ce n'est pas égale son antonyme
c'est identique rien à voir avec une
question de valeurs
souvent se reprend ma fille lorsqu'elle
veut pas finir son assiette et qu'elle
me dit
maman ce n'est pas bon je la reprends et
je lui dis
ma chérie ne me dis pas que ce n'est pas
bon dis que tu n'aimes pas
pas vous en gros ne remet pas la qualité
nutritive des épines à la valeur des
épinards juste parce que c'est différent
du goût des pâtes et qu'accessoirement
tu n'aimes pas ce goût
bref cette comparaison exprime bien mon
point de vue sur la différence
et je vous propose d'associer cette
carte de la différence avec la carte
acceptation de soi j'entends par là
s'assumer alors je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure de mes 23 frères et soeurs hyper
pratique pour éviter les sujets
complexes en entretien n'est pas que
derrière ma vie bien rangée de
banlieusards parisienne je peux me la
couler douce vivons cachés vivons
heureux postant sur instagram de belles
images
mais entre nous à quoi cela ne sert si
ce n'est que de complexer ce qu'ils ne
se retrouvent pas dans ces images
d'epinal alors que le simple fait de sa
fiche est telle qu'on né peut lever
tellement de doutes
et permettent à d'autres
d'être moins complexé et de reprendre
confiance
alors
rencontrons nous
misons sur la carte rencontre de l'autre
j'ai eu la chance
plus jeunes de faire une très très belle
rencontre
j'intervenais en zone d'éducation
prioritaire
j'étais étudiante une anonyme il faisait
un peu de soutien scolaire et autres
activités et j'ai croisé cette petite
fille
j'ai longtemps échangé sur mon parcours
et ce sans mon masque de l'étudiant de
l'école parisienne
et c'est quoi un assez pris d'affection
voir à d'admiration pour moi mais
pourquoi
je suis pas bien c'est un
et ben parce qu'elle s'est reconnue en
moi une jeune femme qui comme elle
n'était pas né au bon endroit dans les
meilleures conditions mais qui avait su
se frayer un chemin dans un monde qui
lui paraissait si inaccessible
c'est tania est là pourquoi pas moi
je vous en fait la confidence elle m'a
donné envie d'agir à mon échelle je vous
dirais même plus elle m'a éclairé et
permis d'admettre que nous pouvons tous
être des role models tout simplement en
levant le voile sur son histoire en
racontant son histoire
racontée vous raconter ce qui a jalonné
votre parcours et pas seulement le côté
visible de l'iceberg
l'invisible mérite d'être découvert et
le tout peut être fort utile et
inspirant pour de
vraiment inspirant pour d'autres
donc est ce que vous voulez savoir on
parle d'inspiration là ce qui moi m'a
inspiré quelle a été ma carte
inspiration
alors si vous dit pas oui
du coup j'ai un problème je peux pas
continuer donc là on dit oui
mais accord
alors ma carte inspiration
les feux de l'amour
non j'ai dit que je m'assume et les feux
de l'amour
petite je regardais cette série avec
maman
et je rêvais des tailleurs et 3 et des
bords chine xxl de ses personnages
féminins
mais comment moi petite fille de
couleurs d'une classe sociale plus que
modeste j'allais faire pour rentrer dans
ce monde toc toc toc la porte des élites
laissez moi entrer on est d'accord c'est
compliqué mais je savais que pour y
parvenir pour réussir il fallait que je
comprenne comment ça marche il fallait
que je prenne cet ascenseur social
et vous savez quoi cet ascenseur il est
accessible par l'éducation l'école les
études alors j'ai redoublé d'efforts
pour apprendre à parler ce langage de
grands hommes ou du moins les imiter et
je crois bien que j'ai réussi j'ai
grimpé cet interminable d'échelle bac
scientifique prépas écoles gros contrats
et
tailleurs brushing
et ouais
mais comment avais compris tout ça dès
le plus jeune âge
moi ce sens plan une fois que j'ai
visualisé là où juliette j'ai tout
simplement demander mon chemin y a pas
plus un plan il n'ya pas de honte à
poser des questions il n'y a pas de
mauvaises questions il faut être curieux
joue online notre carte de la curiosité
ça me rappelle une anecdote perso enfin
plutôt pro
je travaillais sur une présentation
importante et faute de temps j'ai pas
j'ai pas vérifié même source j'ai mis
comme source bea au
je fais ma présentation est la question
que signifie b à o
g neige explique la situation
bouche à oreille
alors toute l'assemblée avait sa réponse
et n'avait plus besoin de faire semblant
de connaître ce nom du grand organisme
de conseil que j'avais inventé de toutes
pièces
merci infir collègues d'avoir posé la
question
veut y aller
je voulais revenir à la carte chance à
la chance j'ai parlé beaucoup de chance
mais cette fois ci je vous propose
de parler de la carte chance du monopoly
vous savez celle vous on peut bien moche
et en cart champ ce genre de paye
carte prison
je vous propose de faire comme au
monopoly et de considérer que la carte
prison est une carte chance
ça titille votre curiosité
bon je vais vous dire je lisais un
article sur les réseaux sociaux et
l'hymne interpellé il disait qu'il
fallait remercier les personnes qui nous
ont mis dans l'est des bâtons dans les
roues
les personnes qui n'ont pas cru en nous
a vraiment là il faut
mais en l'appliquant sur mon parcours
effectivement ces personnes là
constituent de très belles rencontres
l'une de mes premières rencontres avec
la discrimination a été ma maîtresse de
maternelle
si elle m'écoute aujourd'hui j'aimerais
la remercier car grâce à elle grâce
beckham est mise à l'écart j'étais
motivé à faire des études
j'étais motivé à albi prouver à me
prouver que peu importe mon origine l'un
porte ma naissance peu importe ma classe
sociale peu importe où je vais y arriver
et j'irai le plus loin possible dans les
études et c'est comme ça que dès l'âge
de 5 ans je me suis donné comme objectif
de faire de très très très long des
études et j'ai réussi
impensable à l'époque
cette maîtresse m'a challenge et elle
m'a donné le goût aux études
je vous propose de faire une pause
pensez à votre carte chance à votre
rencontre chanceux
accordons-lui là ici maintenant trois
secondes et vous allez la remercier
on y va
merci à thézan non
le monde est injuste est ainsi fait et
alors
le groupe iam chante alors c'est fini la
chanson pour moi
personne ne joue avec les mêmes cartes
je dis pas que les miens étaient les
pieds non c'est pas le but de mon
intervention je ne suis pas là pour vous
exhiber le château que j'ai fait avec
mes cartes j'en suis très fière oui mais
je sais aussi qu'il est fragile que rien
est acquis
mais c'est aussi cette fragilité qui en
fait sa beauté je suis là pour vous
montrez que vous avez toutes les cartes
en main aussi mauvaise qu'elle puisse
vous paraître
l'essentiel est bien souvent invisible
pour les yeux ouvrier un peu plus pour
apercevoir votre essentiel personnel
pour trouver votre équilibre
entre nous ne vous êtes-vous jamais
demandé quels étaient les cartes de
votre voisin tout sens du récit ralliant
mais à quels critères correspondent ils
auquel ne correspond-il pas s'en fait
tout
j'ai l'intimé conviction que personne
n'a le jeu de cartes parfait allez je
vous donne un défi demain
demandez à votre voisin de vous dévoiler
son jeu de cartes
et vous verrez qu'avec ses cartes
qu'avec vos cartes qu'avec nos cartes
nous avons tout en main pour construire
le château dans lequel nos rêvant d'être
tu peux aussi être cette rencontre
éclairantes ce petit raz-de-marée qui
fait déborder sur les vies des flots
devient un levier de bienveillance ces
petits coups de pouce qui n'ont l'air de
rien mais qui peuvent tout changer
c'est pourquoi je te propose d'être à
notre tout cette petite voix qui
répétera sans cesse
vas-y fonce
soit fière de toi t'as singularité est à
force et non au fardeau c'est ok de
penser à auteuil the box c'est ok de te
battre pour qui tu veux être
c'est ok de te lever et de tout casser
tu as de la valeur ne laisse personne te
convaincre du contraire
construit de tes cartes le plus solide
des châteaux personnel fait de ta vie
une ode à la détermination à l'audace à
la chance aux rencontres à
l'authenticité à l'assurance à la pensée
positive
car après tout notre point de départ
ne détermine pas notre point d'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]